okay so in Attack on Titan part 3 there
were a ton of hidden Clues and
references that were easy to miss and so
in this video we're going to be going
through the episode scene by scene to
explain some of the smaller details and
also to explain certain character
motivations starting off with the
opening scene between Aaron Mikasa the
interesting thing about this is that
it's actually the third version of this
same interaction so the original version
came in the manga about 13 years ago
when Aaron woke up under the tree and he
had a dream of Mikasa saying see you
later Aaron now what was interesting
about that version is that you can
clearly tell this is a young version of
Mika so you can tell from the rounded
face and from our height that is clearly
Mikasa as a child now in the anime
version in episode 1 season 1 they
change everything completely so instead
of Aaron waking up from a peaceful dream
he instead had a super aggressive
nightmare where he saw his mother
getting eaten he saw soldiers dead he
saw Titans just roaming around and yeah
he woke up from that so that dream was
completely different so in the anime
episode 1 they changed from the manga
now in part three this is a third
version which is in in many ways it's
actually different from the previous two
I will say you can clearly tell me
because it does say see you later in
this version as well but you can also
tell that this is an adult version of
vikasa so when we look at her face it's
less rounded it's more chiseled like the
adult version of Mikasa um she's also
taller as well so yeah we have three
versions of this one scene I guess you
could say this is now the most Canon
version of them all because it's the
latest version I assume the sa armored
probably has some input on this episode
as well as you know the other final
episode that's gonna come so out of all
the three this is the one that we should
pay the most attention to alright so
following on from the opening scene we
then switch over to Mali where I'm
introduced to Ramsay and halil who are
brothers or cousins I mean they have the
same grandfather so it's going to be one
of those two and now the reason I'm
highlighting this scene is because we
have seen Ramsay a couple times before
the first time that we as an audience
saw him was during the episode two
brothers
um because if you guys remember when
Aaron went into the past Dimension he
saw a bunch of different Visions
including things from like alternate
realities and uh one of those Visions
was of Ramsay now that's the first time
we saw him as an audience but obviously
by this point in the timeline when Aaron
had the vision of Ramsay he already he
already knew who Ramsey was now the
second time we saw him was during the
episode dawn of humanity when he stole
Sasha's purse and one thing about that
is that when he did that and when he was
caught there was a group of malians that
surrounded him and they literally said
they were going through all these
different punishments that they might
give him to stop him from stealing again
and one person literally said we should
smash his hand to stop him from
pickpocketing again when you look at
Ramsay now he clearly is missing his
right hand so either they chopped it off
or they smashed it so badly that he had
to get it decapitated or amputated
clearly after the scouts left at some
point in the future after that he got in
trouble again and they were like you
know what we're tired of you let's just
smash your hand also speaking about the
episode dawn of humanity there was a
moment in that episode when Aaron went
missing for a while and so after that
they all went searching for him
basically for the rest of the day a and
what this episode in part three is
showing us is that when he went missing
he was actually just walking through the
streets of Mali looking at people and
being like damn I'm really gonna kill
these people we have to understand that
fundamentally Aaron didn't want to do
this initially however with everything
that's happened at this point in the
timeline he's kind of accepted that yeah
I am gonna have to kill these people
these are real people who were going to
die now as he's walking through the city
he then sees Ramsay getting beaten up in
one of the Alleyways and just looking at
the footage again these guys were
enjoying it a little bit too much
because Ramsey Ramsey's were like eight
years old like yeah they didn't have to
do him like that and this is when Aaron
has a bit of a crisis because he knows
for a fact that one day he's going to
kill Ramsay he's gonna do the rumbling
it's gonna Crush Ramsay so from a moral
perspective if you know you're going to
kill someone in the future what's the
point of you saving them now what's the
point of you acting like a hero when you
know this person you're saving you're
going to kill so that's the crisis that
Aaron has in this scene it's why for a
moment he does hesitate and he kind of
just like walks out out of the other way
because yeah like I said he's gonna kill
this kid so why would he save him what's
the point But ultimately Aaron does
still go back he beats the guys up he
saves Ramsay and this is what leads to
two more Easter eggs so the first Easter
egg if we look back at the previous
episode there was a moment when mixer
finds Aaron and we see that down there
Ramsay is kind of just like waving to
him but now we know it's because Aaron
possibly even saved his life the next
Easter egg is what Aaron says to Ramsay
which is that he kind of like breaks
down and starts crying and there are two
key reasons why he's crying right now
reason number one he's realizing for the
first time that to save eldia he's gonna
have to kill real innocent people that's
something that until he came here he
didn't fully understand when he was
standing on the beach in season three
looking out he was like yeah what if we
kill our enemies because at that time
his enemies were an abstract concept now
that he's in Mali now that he's seeing
kids like Ramsay who are completely
innocent knowing that they're going to
die because of what he's going to do he
feels guilty for it and that's why he's
apologizing he's basically saying I'm
sorry I'm doing this but I have to do it
to save my people but in addition to
that saving the people isn't his only
reason the second reason is that he was
severely disappointed at what the
outside world is if we run it back for a
second if we put ourselves in Aaron's
shoes for all of his life he's believed
that outside the walls were these things
that he saw in Almond's book the lava
the planes of sand the the icy
Landscapes all these amazing things will
be on the walls and the only thing
standing between him and reaching those
things which those things are freedom to
him freedom is seeing those things and
the only thing standing between Aaron
and those things were the Titans that's
what he believed for most of his life
now when he finally defeated the Titans
and was able to go outside the walls and
do whatever he wanted he realized I'm
still not free because these humans
outside the walls are stopping me from
you know seeing the things that I read
about an armin's book so he was
disappointed at the fact that there's
another enemy across the sea and he's
also disappointed the fact that the
things he read about where are they you
know he expected to see those things he
can't see them because there are humans
who are trying to kill him so that is
also a secondary reason why he wants to
do the rumbling he wants to wipe
everything away and just start again and
Achieve that dream of freedom and it's
why when we have this scene later on
Aaron appears as a kid as he's achieving
freedom because ultimately on the inside
the version of Freedom that he's trying
to get is the one he's wanted ever since
he was this age you know ever since he
was a kid this is what he wanted and so
I I think that's why we see him as a
child as he's um achieving that Freedom
by wiping out Humanity so yeah as Ramsay
and Hillel are running away from the
rumbling they do drop the money and um a
little this is a really small detail but
I did like how on the money you see
clearly that hellos is there so hellos
is like the guy who defeated the
founding Titan 100 years ago and so he's
become such a staple of mali's culture
that he is on the currency which is I'm
I'm pretty sure that detail was never in
the manga or at least I never saw it so
yeah I thought that was a pretty cool
detail now this scene of Ramsay dying
was insane like he opens his eyes he
sees his brother dead in front of him
his legs broken so he can't move and
then the Colossal foot just crushes him
like that's it's insane imagery it's
insane but the one thing I wanted to
highlight about this scene is that as
Ramsay's dying he literally sees the
founder yumiya standing in front of him
it is possible that Ramsay is a subject
of Emir and the reason I say that is
because in the previous episode the
Marlins were speculating that he could
be an aldian you know they were talking
about that and it you only need to have
one alien parent to be an aldian you
know you don't need to look like the
people of parodies you can look like
anyone
um so it is possible that he is a
subject of Emir now personally I don't
think he is because if he was an alien
then he would have heard Aaron's message
and he would have been more aware that
the rumbling was coming um so that's the
reason why I don't think he is but we
can't deny that he is seeing her in this
moment as the Rambler continues there
were a few other things that I thought
all worth pointing out so number one
Aaron's the remnants of Aaron's fight
with the Warhammer Titan it's still
there the spiral on the left is from
when Lara basically shot Aaron into the
air and then tried to decapitate him and
the second little Warhammer bit here
that was created when she basically used
up the last bit of energy she had to try
and kill him but yeah those two pieces
those two remnants of the fight is still
there like months later which I thought
was kind of interesting in addition to
that we have Annie's childhood
neighborhood being destroyed
um you can tell it's her neighborhood
because of the the punching bags which
her dad used to try to you know train
her to be a warrior so that's destroyed
as well and the best anime Edition this
was the thing that I loved I was not
expecting this we see Aaron's
grandparents so Aaron's grandparents
have been locked in a prison cell
presumably because of Zeke's betrayal
everyone found out that he was a traitor
pretty early on after the battle in
Liberia and so I'm assuming that
immediately after that that's when
Aaron's Grandparents were put into jail
if you look closely this area where
they're being held captive is actually
the same place where Zeke was uh when
Zeke was awarded a candidate they put
him on like cleaning Duty and this is
the same place where he was walking
through the hallway and then he
overheard that they were about to find
the elding restorationists so this
building has some significance because
it's the place where Zeke heard
something that changed his entire life
if he wasn't there on that day it's
possible he would have died a long time
ago as well anyway for the rest of this
scene it's it's just the rumbling
destroying Liberia one thing I liked is
that it really showed it was really
realistic what they're showing here we
see people stealing you know which is
what always happens during any natural
disaster but then they're stealing and
then getting crushed a second later
another thing was the fact that
regardless of whether you're rich or
poor you're gonna get trampled you know
we see the rich guy in his car trying to
run away and we see the poor people
running next to him all of them across
regardless like it don't matter who you
are you're gonna die the anime also
conveys really well how hot the Titans
are because when they approach the
foreign it kind of set on fire
immediately and in the streets of
Liberia there are people who have been
burnt to a crisp they've not even been
trampled this the heat from the Titans
is just so hot they just got burnt to a
crisp now after Armin appears in the
past Dimension because of Aaron he then
gets brought back into the real world
and we see of basically him and Annie
having a lot of romantic tension the
just for me personally the reason I
never minded it is because from Annie's
perspective it makes perfect sense why
she'd have some sort of crush on Armin
you know she's been locked in this
Crystal for years and Armin he's the
only person who voluntarily went to say
hi to her to talk to her when it came to
Hitch the only reason hitch was there is
because it was her job she was told by
the military police you know you're the
one who's going to look after Annie's
Crystal so she was there all the time
for Armin he was voluntarily going there
all the time for years to talk to Annie
to literally just speak to a a dead
person okay she wasn't dead but you know
what I mean he was going out of his way
to speak to her to say hi to her to look
at her and on one occasion to try and
touch her so I guess she appreciates
that and she even says it in this video
if she says it in this episode that she
was grateful for it it was the only joy
she had so in that sense you can easily
see why she would develop some kind of
feelings for him over these years
because she sees how much he cares about
her now why does he care about her this
is the part where it gets a bit weird
because it's because of berthought crush
on any that it's basically been
transferred to Armin so he feels these
feelings of love for her largely because
of what Berta was feeling so that's the
only weird part about this but from
Annie's point of view I do see why she
appreciates him why she kind of likes
him in this way and also one other thing
just before we move on even back in
season one Annie did respect Armin a lot
there was a moment during the female
Titan Arc where she could have easily
killed him she could have easily killed
him she killed a lot of other people and
she basically she was about to kill John
as well right so she doesn't mind
killing people in her own class but it
was almond specifically that she was
like you know what she she sped his life
so she's always had some kind of
feelings of respect towards him so we've
got to take that into account as well
that this romance even though it does
kind of seem out of the blue because
we've not seen her for so long it does
still make sense based on the things
that we're talking about but anyway when
the scouts eventually make it to odohar
they see that the entire city is empty
basically everyone's evacuated even
though the population of odohara is gone
there are still dogs animals left behind
and it just reinforces that Aaron isn't
just killing Humanity he's destroying
all life outside the walls that includes
dogs it includes horses it includes
plant life trees all these other things
that make the planet what it is he's
just wiping everything away obviously
killing all humans on the planet is
terrible and you know that in itself is
bad but this kind of just reminds you
know Aaron's going a little bit too far
don't you think like he's killing
everything all life I'm just thinking
that you know it reinforces to me that
Aaron is not a good person you know we
shouldn't be supporting him and doing
the rumbling because there's a lot of
innocent creatures and innocent people
who are gonna die for they don't they
don't even have they don't even have a
role in this conflict and they're gonna
die regardless so yeah it just kind of
reinforces we shouldn't be supporting
the rumbling in case you didn't know now
when the alliance bring the flying boat
into the hangar to you know fuel it up
and get it ready to go in the air
there's a couple things worth pointing
out now the first thing is that the
explosives are still on there those
explosives were originally put on the
flying boat by the the jaegeris you know
Daz and Samuel put it on there so that
they could blow it up in case it needed
to be blown up because as far as the
agarist knew as long as they destroyed
the flying boat then no one could stop
the rumbling because the flying boat was
the only way to get off the island
um since then up until now those
explosives have still been on the boat
and what I didn't like about this is
that Reiner in this scene he's kind of
like let's just cut him off and throw
them away and arm is the one who steps
in and he's like no no why don't we hold
on to the explosives implying that
they're going to use it on Aaron at some
point you would expect that the people
who want to who are willing to kill
Aaron the most would be someone like
Rhino or someone like peek you don't
really expect it to be Armin saying
let's hold on to this stuff but yeah I
just didn't like the idea that arm is
the one who suggests that they hold on
to these things to kill Aaron instead of
you know instead of Aaron's enemy saying
it you know it'll be different if Pika
said this because that would have made
sense
um but for armor to say it yeah I never
really liked that but you guys let me
know what you think in the comments down
below Mikasa feels like Aaron isn't the
true Aaron right now she feels like what
he's doing isn't really him and so
that's what Mikasa believes right now so
she's going to get him and bring him
back and it's why she's not wearing the
scarf because even though she has the
scarf with her like she says the reason
she's not wearing it is because tamikasa
the scarf represents it represents Aaron
being a good person I mean it represents
a lot of things but above everything
else it's the scarf represents home and
it represents Aaron being a good person
because he was the one who gave her the
scarf during her lowest moment he's the
one who gave her hope when she had no
hope when she was depressed because her
parents had been murdered so Taha that
scarf represents him being good and him
being the normal Aaron and right now
he's not the normal Aaron in her in her
mind and so if she doesn't want to wear
it for now but once or if she brings
Aaron back that is when she would put it
on another detail is that Yellen
revealed the existence of a research
base in the south of Mali and that
Fortress is called for Salter what's
relevant about this is that during the
episode two brothers when Aaron was
going into pods he saw a vision of Fort
Salter and when he saw that Vision there
was a giant bird flying in front of it
um so that ties into what Falco says
later in the episode and we'll talk
about that but for now we need to
acknowledge that Aaron saw the future
when he saw Fort Salter and there was a
bird next to it which has a lot of
relevance now the next day is the
alliance get ready to go we see that
Levi yeah he only has two fingers left
on his right hand but for him
specifically this isn't actually such a
bad thing we've seen in the past that
Levi is the only character to
occasionally hold his swords backwards
sometimes and when he holds it this way
it's his pinky finger and his ring
finger that are you know that are locked
in there so he's the only person who
knows how to use the swords and the odm
gear with a pinky finger and a ring
finger and so in the situation even
though he's only got the pinky in the
ring he can still actually use the odm
gear because he has the experience which
I thought was a cool detail and it
definitely shows his Yama had been
planning ahead for this because like I
said it's not like Levi's learning from
scratch he already knows how to use
these two fingers to use the odm gear
this scene between Levi and harji was
honestly great hanji essentially asked
Levi do you think that our fallen
comrades are watching us do you think
they're proud of us and this is a
parallel of what Commander Evan said
back in the Battle of shiganshenna in
that moment Irvine was kind of like he
knew that he'd have to give up on his
dream to defeat the Beast Titan it was
the guilt of knowing that his comrades
were watching him that made him feel
like he should do the plan and obviously
then Levi made the decision for him and
you know convinced him to do it but
Urban always had the belief that their
comrades were watching and I guess hanji
is now adopting that and it's what I
Levi says you know don't stop talking
like him I thought it was a pretty cool
parallel so as they finish preparations
for the flying boat to take off flock
suddenly appears out of nowhere and this
was actually incredible it shows an
incredible level of willpower to hold on
all the way from eldia to to odoha I
would imagine it's the distance between
like England and France like that was a
long ass time that was a long trip that
you were just hanging on there and we
have to remember as well flock was
injured you know he got hit by Gabby so
he was not in a good condition but he
held on the entire way he had that
willpower that's comparable to Aaron
himself and his goal was to shoot the
ship damage it as much as possible and I
gotta say his death was way more
gruesome in the anime than I remember it
being in the manga Mika says shoots his
neck with the odm gear and his body is
just his body is just there it's just
suspended in the air like
that is really messed up that that is
not what I was expecting to see in this
episode but yeah like on agapong says
flock shot a hole in the fuel tank so
that it created a brand new dilemma
because with the flying boat being
damaged like this it meant that they
needed way more time to get it fixed and
obviously the whole time they've been in
odoha the Rumblings are getting closer
and closer to them so the timing really
couldn't have been worse you know they
need an hour to fix this ship and as
that hour comes around the rumbling is
right around the corner so yeah terrible
terrible time it couldn't have been
worse with his dying breath flock begs
them not to go and try and fix the
problem because he literally spells out
for them everyone on the island will be
killed what does he say our Devils oh
our Devils Our Only Hope yeah talking
about Aaron
um that's interesting because he said
the exact same thing about Irvin back in
uh back in shigansha now this scene is
both important and hilarious
um so as they're deciding what they're
gonna do you know how they're gonna
delay the rumbling enough to to you know
get the flying boat back in the air I
thought it was so funny the Reiner
thought he could do something like let's
be for real yeah imagine they actually
said yeah right now go ahead and stop
the rumbling what the hell was he gonna
do like he could he would get swashed
and it's not like his armor is
Invincible his Armor gets broken all the
time so I I can't even imagine what
Rhino was planning to do here
um but yeah he volunteers himself
obviously no one's on board with that
Armin volunteers himself now that was
actually a decent suggestion but as it
turns out in this episode hanji is the
one who sacrifices herself I love this
moment between her and Armin her like
appointing him as the next commander of
the scouts Armin always had potential to
be like Irvin in a sense that he he saw
things other people didn't and he was
able to create intricate plans like
Irvin did and so this is him I guess you
could say coming of age you know it's
him stepping into that role finally and
it's funny because when Army was brought
back I'm pretty sure Levi said to him
like you're never going to replace Irvin
but you know do your best well this is
him now stepping up replacing Irvin and
in being commander of the scouts and I
guess the last thing to mention about it
is the Almond you know like hanji says
he has that special quality in that he's
inquisitive he's intelligent and he has
a desire to understand other people him
and hanji are very similar in that
respect if anyone here
um was going to replace her as as the
commander of the scouts well to be
honest I think Jean could do a good job
as well I think John could have done a
good job but yeah Armin Armin makes
sense too also I love um her and Levi
they have like a telepathic connection
if you guys remember back in uh back
when Elena and their volunteers first
arrive on the island there was that
moment when Levi and hanji they kind of
just looked at each other they didn't
say anything but they were like they
literally they were thinking things and
it was almost as if they could read each
other's thoughts
um and this moment here is like that
they don't need to say much Levi knows
um why hanji is doing this he
understands still super emotional
hanji fighting against the Titans is
amazing and this right here I'm gonna
pause it for a second this shot right
here of hanji in front of the closet
that is amazing that is fantastic this
might be this episode has a lot of
amazing shots so I'm not going to say
this is my favorite shot of the episode
but this is like top five I love this
shot I also like the uh the nice touch
with the anime of them adding uh flock's
body his body being crushed by the
debris this episode in general it added
these little details we saw it earlier
on with like the people killing
themselves during the rumbling all these
small details that you couldn't really
put that in the manga there's just not
enough space to put all these different
things they've really taken advantage of
the fact this is animated they can add
all these extra things
um and I do I really appreciate it and
of course we then get Scout Heaven I
guess you could call it everyone's there
I'm gonna pause it for a second we have
Irvin obviously in the background you
can see instructor chardis is there as
well who hanji used to have a crush on
she used to actually really like him
apparently but yeah what's this guy's
name in the front I think his name is
moblet I'm not sure how to pronounce it
but he was like her right-hand man like
he'd this guy here he died to save her
life when Bertolt did his big colossal
explosion he was the one who pushed her
into the into the well saved her life
really but I guess the main thing we
need to know about this scene the main
thing we need to acknowledge is that by
this scene being a thing this is it
saying I'm telling us that yeah no
matter what Irvin Mike moblet all these
other characters they are in favor of
stopping Aaron destroying the world
which is fair enough you know it's a
reasonable side to be on not wanting to
destroy all life on the planet also
there's uh Irvin basically admitting
like yeah hanji you had it you had it
really bad
um because hanji had to deal with the
jaegeris uprising by force you know they
they assassinated Premier Zachary she
had to deal with Aaron Vanishing and
Marley running away she had to deal with
getting Aaron Back to the Island which
meant people dying and a whole
convoluted plan in Mali it was really
difficult time time to be leader of the
scouts and harji did not have it easy
even before all of that crazy stuff
happened harji was also given the burden
of having to figure out how to make
peace with the outside world because you
know the whole the whole thing was that
you know if we don't make peace with the
outside world then we're gonna have to
do a mini rumbling so for years she had
the job of trying to decide how are we
going to solve this problem this
impossible problem so in many ways you
could say it was almost or equally as
bad as some of the things that Irvin had
to deal with Irvine dealt with a lot too
so we can't pretend like he had it easy
he went through a lot of crap as well
but uh yeah neither of them had it easy
at all so the episode is split into two
chapters so this second chapter is
called Sinners and it kind of just
begins in the aftermath of hanji's death
so now they're flying towards Aaron or
more specifically they're flying towards
Fort Salter and the problem here is that
they only have half the fuel they were
meant to have because of the whole
craziness with flock they couldn't fuel
the the ship properly but onyanka point
is determined to make Aaron no matter
what because as we know the fate of his
own country is on the line as well
so what Armin said just then is a
parallel of something hanji said back in
the raid on Liberia here Army basically
Taps what you can put on the shoulder he
says you know we're in your hands please
get us to uh Fort Salter now back in
Liberia hanji basically said the same
thing she's I think her exact words were
were counting on you and yank upon so
two occasions now the command of the
scouts is said to an agapon you know
we're relying on you we're counting on
you we're in your hands um so yeah I
thought that was a nice parallel there
have been quite a few parallels in this
episode you know we had panji and Irvin
a bunch of different parallels okay so
the alliance then come up with a plan to
stop Aaron now the problem with this
plan is that they don't know for sure
that he's going to be in the nape and so
Pete suggests the idea that they just
blow up the whole thing you know they
get close to the fighting Titan Armin
detonates the largest explosion he can
and that just kills Aaron and just stops
the whole rumbling Armin even admits
that this is the most effective way of
doing it however obviously they want to
talk to Aaron they want to try and talk
him out of doing the rumbling before
they try and kill him or anything like
that so that's plan a plan a is to blow
Aaron up which is not what they want to
do plan B is to talk to Aaron which is
what armor suggested and plan C is
something that Levi suggested which is
that they go for the Beast item now the
idea behind Levi's theory is that if
they kill Zeke if they kill the Titan of
Royal Blood then it means that Aaron
literally won't have the power to
continue the rambling because as we've
established for a long time now Aaron
currently control the founder if he
makes contact with the Titan of Royal
Blood and when the rumbling began Zeke
was literally absorbed into the source
of all living matters so as far as we
know Zeke is inside the fighting Titan
somewhere he's somewhere inside that
pile of bones and also you know no one
in this room has a problem with killing
Zeke you know everyone has a reason why
they would want to kill him the worry is
he betrayed them the scouts they have no
loyalty to him so yeah no one here has
any problem with killing Zeke so that's
what they'd rather do rather than going
straight for killing Aaron himself
something else that I thought was great
about this scene is the scouts realizing
how hard it was for Rhino they never
really empathize with what Rhino had to
go through until this exact moment
because they're basically in the same
position that he was if we look at it
side by side the scouts had to kill
their friends in order to save the world
they're killing their friends in order
to stop Aaron destroying the planet now
when Rhino was younger he basically said
that he wanted to destroy the island
Devils to save the world that was his
main goal but when he got to the island
when he met the island devils and
realized they were just normal people
that's what made it difficult for him
because he became friends with them he
became attached to them and so yeah he
did still betray them and did still go
against them but it was hard and he was
doing it to save the world so they
understand what he was going through
because they're literally doing the same
thing now they've betrayed their people
um now the other thing worth mentioning
about this scene is Armin and Peak you
know they realized that Aaron is letting
them act freely if Aaron wanted to right
now he could probably do some crazy
stuff to these guys he could probably
like like you know you guys remember
that scene in uh in Doctor Strange 2
when Wonder kind of just like removes
that guy's mouth you know if Aaron
wanted to I'm sure he could do that same
thing to everyone in this in this uh
Airship the reason he's not doing it is
because he wants them to have free will
even though he's going towards his goal
of wiping out humanity and achieving
Freedom he's also not going to take away
freedom from arm and meekser and his
friends you know he wouldn't do that so
they have the freedom to try and stop
him if they want but obviously if he's
going for his goal and they're going for
their goal it's inevitable that they're
going to collide and fight at some point
because they have opposite views on
whether they should Rumble Humanity or
not um now Aaron does take them to pods
and there was a detail that I loved
about this scene and that was when they
run towards him as they think they're
getting closer they suddenly end up even
further away Aaron is just messing with
them using the power of the founder
another thing that was an anime only
Edition is that when Mikasa is running
towards him in this scene she sees a
flashback of when they were actually
kids and when she was running after him
and no spoilers but that moment is from
when they were kids and they used to um
basically there was one day when Aaron
suggested they should race to the tree
on the hill and on that day Aaron was in
the lead Mikasa could have easily
overtaken him but she decided to stay
behind him and I think that Vision right
there is from that moment when she let
him run ahead of her as they ran towards
the tree on the hill so the next scene
then switches to the boat where we have
Annie kyomi Falco and Gabby and all of
the uh the his root engineers and the
main takeaway from this scene is the
fact that we learn a few new things
about the Titans thing number one that
we learn is that when a Titan consumes a
part of another Titan they can in some
situations inherit that Titan's
abilities so according to Annie the
female Titans the best at doing this and
it's why she was able to do her scream
to attract Titans she clearly ate the
Beast Titan or something and got his
ability she also has the uh the
hardening you know maybe she got that
from eating equal or potentially Rhino
but the basic idea is that when a tie an
is a part of another Titan they can gain
certain powers now this is what brings
us to Falco because as we all know Falco
accidentally consumes son of the some of
the beast's Titan spinal fluid and this
is way back in uh in part one of the
final season he drank the tainted wine
that had Zeke spinal fluid so by that
definition it means that when he became
a Titan he had the Beast Titans DNA
inside him and it's why he's become this
hybrid between the Beast Titan and a
draw Titan so in many ways Falco isn't
just a draw Titan he is two Titans in
one and it's why in this instance as
he's saying here he can literally
manifest Beast time characteristics he
can see Beast Titan memories not just
Zeke's but other Beast Titans as well
and the clearest memory the memory he
sees most often is of a Titan Flying
high in the sky meaning that in the past
there have been Beast Titans who can fly
because uh Beast Titans can take
different forms it depends on who the
who the user is and when it comes to
Falco since he was introduced to the
series he's had a lot of bird-like
imagery his very first appearance was
him looking up at the sky he saw a bird
he's reaching out to it and then his
name is Falco you know I feel like
that's intentional Falcon Falco
there's a lot of Bud a lot of bird
connections to this character um so it
shouldn't be surprising that he if he
was going to be a Beast Titan it would
be one that could fly but anyway that's
enough rambling uh moving on to the next
scene so this scene is near Fort Salter
there's a train heading towards Fort
Salter and has been hijacked by the
eldians from Liberia so the last time we
saw Annie's dad and all the other
characters they're basically victims of
police brutality like the police
literally kicked them to the ground and
the next thing we heard was a gunshot
and it went black so the implication
back then was that you know they were
shooting the eldings in the atonement
Zone when in reality there was some kind
of Uprising and Annie's dad he was able
to get a lot of the aldians away from
Liberia onto this train heading straight
for Fort Salter and it was a great
strategy as well because you know Fort
Sauter is the only place that has these
airships so if they get the airships
they can kind of fly over the rumbling
and based on the resources they had this
was the best possible option for them to
to do now it's worth pointing out that
on this train is uh Reiner's mother we
got peak's Dad we have Gabby's parents
Gabby and uh and falcus parents as well
so when the warrior parents and their
families then make it to the top of the
fort they realize that every single one
of the ships is gone like there's not a
single one left but it's because they've
all been deployed to attack the founding
Titan literally all the remaining
airships were being focused on this one
bombing run and essentially their main
goal here was to get close to the
founding Titan but not too close but
close enough to that when they drop the
bombs it can all be concentrated on his
head and on his neck which would in all
likelihood it would decapitate the
founding ties and it would blow Aaron's
head off but the key is that they have
to be close enough so that all the bombs
are concentrated in this one area if
they're too high up in the sky then the
bombs are going to be too separated and
you know they're not going to be
effective
um I said yeah the plan was to get close
close ish to Aaron in this moment we
then get nice anime original flashback
of rana's mom and she's kind of just
realizing for the first time that she
you know obviously she loves Reiner but
she's realizing that she's used him as a
tool to kind of like further herself she
made him into a warrior
um by the way before I even get any that
was horrifying that image right there
why did they draw her like that she's
just like something from it or something
I don't know
um but what she's saying here is that
the whole time you know I treated my boy
as a tool for Revenge I've still never
done a single motherly thing for him and
this is a theme that you can probably
see with a lot of the warrior parents
especially Annie's dad who he adopted
her to mold her into a soldier that
would give him a better life that was
the whole reason he got her in the first
place
um so he kind of empathizes with uh with
what runner's mother is saying but I
also you know you can also empathize
with the parents themselves because at
the end of the day the only chance they
had for a better life inside the entire
Zone was to do what they did so although
it's not the best and although they
didn't maybe treat their kids like
normal kids you can't be too hard on
them they they did what they did based
on the terrible circumstances that they
were put in unfairly by the malians In
This Moment is the ship's approach Aaron
then activates the Fanning Titan but as
the bombs are falling Aaron literally
crates his own Beast Titan out of Titan
hardening it's fully flexible it it's
almost as if it was Zeke himself but
it's not Zeke it's not Zeke we need to
emphasize that this is essentially a
clone of Zeke made purely out of time
hardening and because it is made out of
hardening it's able to create these
rocks in its hand that it's able to
throw but yeah once again we need to
emphasize this is not Zeke because the
real Zeke does not support anything
Aaron is doing the real Zeke wanted
ultimately he wanted a solution that led
to the end of the eldian race while at
the same time allowing them to live out
their lives in peace whereas his crazy
brother wants to eliminate all life on
the planet so big difference but there's
a big difference between their
ideologies and so the real Zeke would
never have supported Aaron in his way he
never would have wiped out the airships
this is purely Aaron controlling
um of fake Warhammer Beast Titan with
Aaron then destroying those airships it
meant that all hope was lost for
Humanity because those ashes he
destroyed were the last ones there
aren't any more in in storage that was
it however as we can see here the scouts
then show up at the last second and they
get bombarded by the fake Beast Titan if
we assume that Aaron is controlling the
fake Beast Titan it's quite a risky move
for him to throw rocks at the ship that
has all your friends on it you know what
if what if one of those had just
happened to go throughout the front
windshield and like went straight for
Mikasa or straight for arm and killed
them like
playing with fire a little bit Aaron's
playing with fire but um this scene is
so well animated though so the people on
the side they can see what's going on
um Ryan's mother is obviously super
emotional to see him because
realistically she thought she was never
going to see him again he was the last
time she heard he was on the island
having you know done The Invasion with
commander mcgathon and the Marlins so as
far as she knew he was probably dead but
he might be alive I don't think she was
ever expecting that he'd show up out of
nowhere tackle the Beast Titan and you
know be be part of this operation to to
stop the rumbling so um from her
perspective this has got to be insane
from Annie's dad's perspective obviously
Annie isn't here
um so he hasn't he doesn't see her but
he's always been the parent who believed
that his child was alive even when no
one else believed that he maintained
that Annie was still alive on the island
I'm sure Annie's dad must be wondering
where the hell is Annie you know you got
Peak you got Rhino where's Annie
um
so that's definitely going to be um
something that will that will be touched
on again but overall I mean that episode
was amazing I
see my favorite episode of Attack on
Titan was two brothers I've referenced
that episode a couple times already I've
watched it so many times it two brothers
is my favorite but this was
I mean this was something else wasn't it
this was basically a movie it was an
hour long longest episode of the series
we've ever had is this I'm just trying
to work out in my head is this my
favorite episode or is it still two
brothers I'm trying to figure out there
was nothing more they could have done to
reach a 10 out of 10. so yeah I'm giving
it a 10 out of 10. this was a fantastic
episode fantastic movie I loved it
um
is it better than two brothers I guess
this episode has the advantage of being
longer so there's more content as well
um I don't know I don't know I'm gonna
say this is my joint favorite episode
this is my joint favorite episode of
Attack on Titan this and two brothers
until the next one I'd appreciate if you
subscribe hit that like button and do
all the other good stuff that helps the
algorithm and uh and yeah let me know in
the comments down below what was your
favorite part of the episode until the
next one peace out